when you were on AGT I always did jokes
I told you I was gonna talk about this a
little bit I always did jok rap gifts
well I gave you one back he bought me a
slipper a a metal no that was nice that
was was gave I know you gave it back he
actually tried really was it was a candy
it was a it was a pure silver $500 candy
tray flop it was a flipflop that you put
candy it back and he it's in her house
now and what do you use it for candy
it's keys I use it to put keys keys at
the front
door it was pure silver but that was a
serious thing she goes I'm not going to
[__] have that then listen what
happened as a joke terrible gift no I'm
yelling but listen to this as a joke we
were in New York for the rap gift I went
to a pet store I paid the guy $1,000 he
had all these parakeet and I said can I
borrow can I rent the parakeet I didn't
know you'd rented it I know can I rent
the parakeets for an hour so I delivered
parakeet and they were going to it was
like a funny joke to all my castmates
you and everybody else with a not
brought back on the jet I know you which
is an it's me don't worry about it it's
uh with notes that said that they were
special uh Parisian par yeah they
believed it and how to care for them
they had to stay in a room no less than
80 degrees they had to be fed every 19
minutes they live to be three years old
each of these is two years n months old
yeah and I mine lived a long time well
that was it was [__] you weren't I
was giving you supposedly old high
maintenance parakeets that are going to
live for another three months and I gave
them to everybody in the room Howard
Stern got mad at me yelled at me talked
about it on the radio and I got in
trouble from Peta because he's an animal
activist I know but I wasn't doing two
so she took two home I I didn't pay for
them I know but they weren't real it was
just for they were real they were prop
Birds I I know but it wasn't a really a
gift well you didn't say it and now I'm
going to take the gift back I got
attached I named these two birds you get
attached you had it for 15 minutes no I
didn't I got attached and they they
survived quite some time well listen
Okay so she takes one flew out of my
apartment and I had to hire somebody to
come and get it a parakeet catcher a
bird catcher okay but before that yeah
we they used to fly us privately back
from New York yeah she took the two
birds yes two birds no cage that sounds
like a really bad video two two girls
one cup yeah that's what the reference
that's the reference did you ever see
that yeah what do you think I don't
understand why people do that to each
other I know have two cups so so anyway
they they they uh you brought the birds
back on a plane yeah that was a present
that you gave me so in my mind I I'd
already given a present back I'm keeping
these and I'm going to be gracious right
she gave back a piece of silver
she carried two birds that weren't hers
home in a plane and the flight attendant
the flight attendant was I don't know if
you remember
this deathly afraid of birds first of
all who gets in the I ended up getting
them really T they would go on my finger
they were flying all over the plane the
flight attendant was screaming nobody
could get water you're going don't hurt
the bird don't hurt the bird these are
for the kids do you remember I got in
the plane wait do you remember what I
got you no
what'd you get me you don't
remember yes I do I stuck it on I stuck
it on everyone's door dildos really big
dildos yeah I didn't know that was a
gift I just thought you were using my
room anyway the thing is that did you
take that home it was really big Rich
yes did you take it oh tell oh I took it
home did you take it you had you had a
big this giant black dildos I remember
remember this yeah and then as a joke
you had a a a party at your house you
not as a joke you had a party at your
house a birthday party yeah remember was
a surprise party where you made the wine
cups and you you wrote our names on it
so I thought it'd be kind of funny to
regift so I brought a little bag wait
wait I brought the little bag with a
giant black dildo and came to the house
and that's all I had and I rang the
doorbell because I was going to your
house and Maddie Madison answer at the
door yeah MADD is at the time is her
four-year-old daughter answers the door
and she goes is that a present for Mommy
I go no she goes mommy said I could take
the presents she grabs the presents and
the last image I have is your
four-year-old daughter running upstairs
with with a 9in black dildo going
mommy anyway but you know what's really
funny is Heidi thought that that present
was
serious and she really liked it okay
okay those Germans the more you know
no she was like thank you okay thank you
very much all right all right I don't
know how to comment on that but that's
clickbate that'll be good anyway what
else what was I saying okay so you took
the birds home the birds and you took
the dildo home and the bird died right
you're not good with eventually they
died and